Lemon / Donaghy
Turing / Clarke
Biden / Obama
Sajack / White
Bush / Rice
Kathy Lee / Hoda?
Knope / Swanson
Dominguez / Dilworth?
Howdy productive members of corporate society,
Trace and Crystal here for DNews.
You may have heard the term "work wife" or
"work husband" -- basically it's a platonic
partner in your office, separate from your
actual partner.
Basically, a 'work spouse' is
a non-romantic significant other,
like your BFF at work.
According to informal online surveys done
by career websites like Captivate and Vault,
around 60 percent of people said they had
a work spouse.
A work-wife, or work-husband is a super-interesting
and fairly new development for researchers!
It was only defined in the journal Communication
Studies in June of 2015!
They were trying to define the idea of a work-spouse
to "chart a course" for "future research for
communication scholars."
Having a work-spouse is *not* the same as
dating a coworker.
It's usually platonic -- so not about seuxal
interest -- instead, it's a way to get mutual
support, have a sounding board for frustrations
and over time the pair forms a strong emotional
connection.
Again though, not sexual.
Platonic.
In fact,
55 percent of those surveyed said
their work-spouse was same sex -- though there's
also the consideration of sexual orientation.
If you're wondering who your office-spouse
is, think about a coworker who you talk to
throughout the day; 21-percent said they talk,
IM or email constantly at work -- mostly talking
about work and co-workers, a bit more than
half talked salary.
But don't think work-spouses are just for
gossip.
For example, to paraphrase the Boston Globe's
Beth Teitell:
"No one has your back like your [work-spouse]!"
Occupational Psychologist Joanna Butler told
the Telegraph, "We're working longer hours…
[and] we're more likely to work in collaborative
environments."
And in those collaborative environments, social
support makes us happy, while researchers
have found again and again that isolation
makes people unhappy.
You can't underestimate the power of a happy
worker.
A study published in the Journal of Labor
Economics found
people who are happy at work are more productive.
They use their time more effectively and work
more quickly without compromising work quality!
And having friends at work does make us happy!
A Gallup poll found close friendships at work
increase employee satisfaction 50-percent!
And the Harvard Business Review writes that
"Friends at work also form a strong social
support network for each other… whether
rooting for each other on promotions, consoling
each other about mistakes, giving advice,
or providing support for personal situations."
Perhaps part of the reason we're just starting
to study this, is because we're just getting
a new term for work-BFFS.
Surely, close friendships have existed at
work before the 21st century, but now with
the tendency of work to go on at all hours.
Maybe they're more important?
True!
If you're not a get-off-my-lawn Baby Boomer,
you know Millennials are not a lazy generation,
but rather that seventy-three percent work
more than 40 hours a week…
...and nearly a quarter work over 50!
On top of that, millennials are more likely
than past generations to have a marriage partner
who
works out of the home, and report that they
have less time to do what they want.
Plus, they're paid less than their Baby Boomer
counterparts.
Bottom-line, all these pressures means Millennials
crave a positive workplace culture -- which
includes making good friends in the workplace.
And that's really what the "work-spouse" really
is, your work BFF.
Some people don't even like the term work-husband
or work-wife, because it does imply so much
more than just a close non-romantic friendship.
Additionally, some researchers have concerns
about falling into traditional gender roles,
and still others fear work-spouses will disrupt
the workplace in general.
But c'mon.
Having a friend who is close in proximity
(like in the same office) can influence your
well-being… because again, having friends
positively impacts your health.
Look, I think we all know work-spouses slash
work-BFFs exist, but way more research is
needed.
But not about you and me right?
Work BFFs?
Obvi.
And if you are one of those working super-long
hours outside the home… maybe like… think
about ways to make your marriage partner feel
appreciated.
We'd like to thank our sponsor Kay Jewelers
for supporting DNews and this episode.
For 100 years, every kiss begins with Kay.
Do you have a work wife?
Work husband?
Tell us in the comments.
Also when it comes to leadership in the workplace
(or elsewhere) who are better: men or women?
That debate happens (with science) on this
video here.